que souhaite la bienvenue au ministère
de la cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
nadia est accueilli par la ministre
jacqueline gourault pour sa prise de
fonction auprès d'elle yvelinoise
devient ministre délégué en charge de la
ville alors en place julien de normandie
qui rejoint le ministère de
l'agriculture
l'ex député de la 11e circonscription
des yvelines va s'occuper des zones
urbaines fortement impacté par la crise
sanitaire
il est deux priorités aujourd'hui sont
évidemment l'emploi parce qu'il faut que
l'emploi que la relance économique
arrive dans ces quartiers aussi et
l'éducation parce que cette période de
confinement a eu un effet très très
grave dans la poursuite scolaire des
enfants
la politique de la ville sera au coeur
de son action une politique globale pour
lutter contre les inégalités sociales
dans les quartiers prioritaires avec
plusieurs dimensions culturelle sociale
économique ou encore éducative un sujet
de préoccupation dans plusieurs communes
de son ancienne circonscription
cette circonscription qui en fait en
réalité je le dis tout le temps une mini
france parce que on part des
problématiques qui peuvent être des
problématiques rurales quand on est sur
la vallée de chevreuse avec la ville du
mesnil-saint-denis comme des
problématiques urbaines importantes
comme la ville de trappes d'action sera
orientée particulièrement sur les
quartiers politique de la ville mais
tous les territoires fragiles et surtout
surtout je le disais tout à l'heure
cette réconciliation entre le rural et
la ville
conséquence directe de sa nomination une
élection législative partielle va être
organisée dans les trois prochains mois
dans la 12e circonscription des yvelines
alors je vous parle je ne suis pas
candidate aux législatives
ça peut évoluer dans les jours à venir
je me donne le temps de la réflexion il
est très clair que nous aurons un
candidat ou une candidate
la république en marge de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines pour rappel
lors du second tour des élections
législatives de 2010 est nadia et
l'avait emporté avec 52 points 96 %
devant le candidat les républicains jean
michel fourgous